this is my favorite take on the crisis
of regime just came out from Roseanne
Barr on Twitter she said the propaganda
here from the other side is sad it's
just a collection of unhinged emotional
outbursts from Trump derangement
syndrome Psychopaths who only hate him
because the war party pedos told them to
I've been mentally ill my whole life and
these people are bat s-h-i-t crazy in
comparison pretty much sums it up
That's it man so if you think if you
think the issue in this in this campaign
is well you know those rates of illegal
immigration are a little bit High I
think we need to curtail those a little
bit you know I just think
I think that those corporations are
getting away with a little bit too much
we might need to regulate them a little
bit more then then you'll
probably try to pick from the ordinary
array of candidates and policies if
however you think that the issues at
play in this campaign are a little bit
deeper if you think that the the fact
that the current president is trying to
imprison his chief political rival is is
not just an aberration but a harbinger
of even more ominous things to come
then you're probably looking at the
election a little bit different and
you're not going to be a one-issue voter
covid or immigration or I don't know any
issue you're going to be looking at the
whole political order now Bobby Kennedy
Jr did just get one in endorsement that
would be from
Woody Harrelson lovable Woody Harrelson
great actor uh he posed with Bobby
Kennedy's wife Cheryl Hines who is the
plays the wife on Curb Your Enthusiasm
with Larry David which is funny because
Larry David's a huge lib and screams at
anyone who's even vaguely conservative
so this sums up the Kennedy campaign to
me the Kennedy campaign is for cool
hippies not ordinary hippies who are
generally insufferable
but cool lovable hippies like Woody
Harrelson
Bobby Kennedy's campaign is for Anodyne
populists people who recognize that
there is something wrong not just with
the Democrat Party not just with the
Republican Party there's something wrong
with the whole system the corporate
media the liberal establishment whatever
term you want to use for it but
they're Anodyne hippies because they're
not going to support a populist
candidate who can actually
gum things up
Kennedy is polling at what 17 percent in
the Democrat Party Democrat Party keeps
a much tighter lock on the primary
process than the Republican Party does
there is a zero percent chance that
Bobby Kennedy becomes the Democrat
nominee for president not going to
happen
but you can feel kind of good because
you say all right baby I'm voting
against the system it's like the people
who voted for Ralph Nader in 2000. it's
like a a glorified version of The Green
Party
now the populists who want to get
something done
they vote for Trump not that that's a
guarantee to get anything done it might
not they might not let him win either
but at least he he has won before at
least he has gummed up the system before
you see this a little more clearly
overseas
the populists who want to get something
done
vote for the brexit they vote for
Georgia Maloney although she has gone a
little bit squishy they vote for Victor
Orban in Hungary
they vote for the Vox party in Spain
they vote for uh
afd in Germany they vote for the
conservative party in Sweden they vote
for
these Insurgent groups that
actually have a shot of winning
but if you don't want to deal with that
you don't want to be called an evil
terrible monster racist this is status
then then you endorse Bobby Kennedy Jr
and you get you get to have your cake
and eat it too you don't you don't
actually get any consequence out of that
but you get to you get some populist
cred without having to deal with the the
downsides of that right now go to
puretalk.com Knowles you know a company
is looking out for you when they upgrade
your service without even charging you
for it it's great news for new and
current Pure Talk customers pure talk
just added data to every plan and
includes a mobile hotspot with no price
increase whatsoever if you've considered
pure talk before but have not made the
switch take a look again for just 20
bucks a month you will get unlimited
talk text and now 50 more 5G data plus
their new mobile hotspot this is why I
love pure talk it's veteran owned they
only hire the best customer service team
located right here in the great us of a
most families are saving almost a
thousand dollars a year while enjoying
the most Dependable 5G Network in
America remember
you vote with how you spend your money
so stop supporting woke wireless
companies that don't support you when
you go to puretalk.com
you'll save an additional fifty five
zero percent off your first month
because they value you
that's puretalk.com
Wireless for Americans by Americans
right now go to prageru.com many
Americans have lost faith in the
government media and schools that's the
bad news the good news is there's
something that you can do to help get
the country back on track prageru is an
educational non-profit that is fighting
to save the future of America watched
five million times a day prageru videos
spread messages of Liberty economic
freedom and the values that built our
country to the Next Generation there
truly is hope for America but only if we
reach more young people and prageru
needs your help go to prageru.com and
make a tax deductible donation whatever
you give right now will be matched and
have twice the impact donate ten dollars
it doubles to twenty give 50 it becomes
a hundred you get the idea seventy
percent seven zero percent of viewers
say their mind was changed after
watching a Prague or you video please
give to prageru today so your gift can
have double the impact in reaching more
people and changing more Minds go to
prairieu.com today whatever you give
will be doubled it is a crisis of regime
though and I don't think I'm being
hyperbolic about that you want to know
my evidence for it my evidence for it is
that the suicide rate just hit an
all-time high
that's probably the best evidence I
could give you that the problem we face
right now is not just one little area of
public policies gone off
or one little part of the government has
become corrupt but that the whole system
is is really rotten the suicide rate or
in recent years has been getting worse
and worse and worse so much so that the
life expectancy in the United States has
declined because of deaths of Despair
overdoses and suicides and now
the suicide rate hit an all-time high 49
500 people killed themselves last year
in the U.S highest number ever
CDC has not yet calculated the official
suicide rate for the year the available
data suggests that suicide rates are
more common in the US than any time
since at least the dawn of World War II
largest increases were in older adults
deaths Rose nearly seven percent in
people ages 45 to 64. Rose more than
eight percent 65 or older and white men
in particular the most maligned group in
the entire country probably in the
entire world have very very high rates
this
tells you that the argument of the uni
party everyone from the Clinton
Democrats all the way over to the Romney
Republicans
has fallen flat and that argument we've
heard it a lot especially over the last
10 20 years is that liberalism is great
and on the right you hear Classical
liberalism is great we just need to
return to the enlightenment values and
on the left you hear liberalism is great
and we need to follow liberalism to its
logical conclusion and be more
Progressive and Kindler and gentler but
we're all going to follow the liberal
program of of what of prioritizing
material benefit which is fine we all
want to be able to eat but prioritizing
material growth over any other
consideration not at all considering the
other things that make a nation a nation
people customs language borders
Traditions all of that is what religion
most of all that's all bunk forget about
that that's for the from the Stone Age
We that doesn't matter anymore now we
have iPhones and iPhones are all that
matters see and when you ever suggest
that maybe there's a problem in the
country a problem that goes a little bit
deeper than one party and goes to the
systemic level what you will hear from
the the line Towers on both sides of the
partisan divide is look things are
better now than they've ever been
deaths in infancy are way way down
they'll tell you look people used to die
in childbirth now those deaths are way
way down you might say yes that's true
because of modern Medical Technology the
problem is no one's having any kids
well okay sure but deaths from war and
violence they're way way down yeah but
people are killing themselves more than
ever oh okay yeah that's true well um
now people aren't stuck in abusive
marriages or marriages for politics or
economic considering that's true just
now no one's getting married
yeah and people are literally killing
themselves
so you it it reminds me of the
Socialists you know the Socialists
always say look socialism it's just
never been tried
we'll say forget about all the all the
actual data on what socialism looks like
in practice let me tell you what it
looks like in theory and this is what
I'm hearing from the Liberals
modern Progressive liberals and
so-called classical liberals all the
same they're basically saying oh no true
liberalism's never been tried oh don't
look at the actual data don't look at
the people killing themselves don't look
at the families collapsing don't look at
the drug overdoses don't look at the
borders falling apart don't look at the
political structure no no just in theory
in theory liberalism is great who cares
if it works in practice does it work in
theory I care if it works in practice
and the millions and millions of
Americans
the many many millions of people across
the West who are voting for these more
populist parties who are questioning the
dogmas of official regime liberalism in
the last few years
we all care if it works in practice much
much more than what you can sketch out
on a chalkboard what a great clip now
now
you gotta ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael Knowles Channel we'll see
you next time